el Primer Ministro tailandés llegó al
lugar por la tarde para presentar su
respetos y depositar un ramo de flores
al pie de esta puerta frente al sitio
donde comenzaron los hechos los
familiares de las víctimas también
estuvieron presentes esta mujer perdió a
su sobrino de dos años y medio
muy conmocionados es como si nuestros
corazones se rompieran en un millón de
pedazos no tenemos palabras sentimos la
pérdida de alguien que amamos dentro de
nosotros
el jueves por la tarde un hombre de 34
años irrumpió en el establecimiento
armado con un cuchillo y una pistola
mató a 23 niños Cuando regresó a casa
mató a su esposa y a su hijo pequeño
antes de quitarse la vida en total al
menos 36 personas murieron en una rueda
de prensa la policía dio más información
sobre el agresor un ex agente de la ley
bajo la influencia de las drogas
la policía local fue informada de su
implicación en el tráfico de drogas y lo
detuvo a principios de 2022 la policía
encontró metanfetamina en su posesión
el viernes iba a ser el día de su juicio
la última matanza de esta magnitud en
Tailandia Fue en Febrero de 2020 un
tiroteo en el este del país que provocó
la muerte de 29 personas